[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
nuestro invitado de hoy es el ex Primer
Ministro de Pakistán in Ram nos acompaña
desde su casa en la Ford casi dos
semanas después de haber sido atacados
durante una protesta contra el gobierno
en la ciudad de guacirabat Muchas
gracias
después del ataque el sospechoso fue
arrestado y confesó que había actuado
por su cuenta y por razones religiosas
pero usted piensa que los verdaderos de
responsables son el Primer Ministro
Sebastián
y un funcionario de los servicios
internos de inteligencia de Pakistán
que ha sido dos semanas después Sigue
pensando lo mismo
fue Primer Ministro durante tres años y
medio las agencias de inteligencia
trabajan bajo mi supervisión entonces sé
cómo operan sé exactamente lo que pasó
lo predije hace casi seis semanas cuando
publicaron un video acusándome de
blasfemia que después fue retomado por
el portavoz del gobierno por la
televisión controlada por el gobierno yo
dije hace seis semanas que todo esto
estaba planeado para asesinarme a través
de un fanático religioso conocemos el
pasado de quienes nombré tanto del
Primer Ministro como del ministro del
interior
durante 30 años ambos han estado
involucrados en asesinatos
extrajudiciales ambos estuvieron
involucrados en lo que se conoce como la
masacre del model Town donde dispararon
contra 12 manifestantes y hubo 60
heridos conocemos su pasado por eso Sé
que cuando hay una investigación
independiente las personas detrás del
ataque habrán sido estos tres hombres y
el señuelo es ese presunto fanático
religioso que en realidad no es una
persona religiosa porque se conocen sus
antecedentes los periodistas los
presentaron así que todo fue montaje
ya nos cuentan exposes
usted habla de una investigación el
Primer Ministro condenó el ataque y
pidió formalmente que el presidente del
tribunal supremo estableciera una
comisión para investigarlo esto es
exactamente lo que usted quiere y creo
que confía en que el presidente del
tribunal supremo para todo lo posible
por averiguar la verdad
eso es cierto le pedí al presidente del
tribunal supremo que se hicieron en
investigación independiente Bajo su
supervisión sabemos que había dos
atacantes porque el señuelo era el
atacante que admitió haber disparado por
razones religiosas Pero sabemos que
también Había otro atacante sé que una
investigación independiente va a
demostrar que lo que estoy diciendo es
verdad que esto fue un intento de
asesinato planeado y que quien más se
benefició fue este gobierno
desde que me destituyeron del poder mi
partido ha crecido ganó 75% de las
elecciones parciales los petrifica
pensar que si hay elecciones vamos a
ganar por eso quieren eliminarme
usted dice que una investigación
independiente lo va a demostrar pero la
pregunta es cree que el presidente del
tribunal supremo podrá llevar a cabo una
investigación así o no Porque según lo
que dice es posible que al ejército al
gobierno a los servicios de inteligencia
no les interese una investigación
independiente
de hecho las agencias de investigación
están bajo la supervisión de esas tres
personas que nombré el ministro del
interior el Primer Ministro y el
funcionario de los servicios de
inteligencia entonces Bajo su
supervisión no hay posibilidad de que se
haga lo que yo creo que sería una
investigación adecuada por eso se lo
pedí al presidente del tribunal supremo
y él debe conformar su propio equipo
debería escoger ese equipo a partir de
distintos departamentos agencias de
inteligencia Y ellos deberían trabajar
bajo la supervisión del presidente del
tribunal supremo Esa es la única manera
de que haya alguna esperanza para que yo
obtenga justicia
unas semanas antes del intento de
asesinato en su contra el jefe de
servicios de inteligencia pakistaníes en
un caso inusual habló con los reporteros
y lanzó varios ataques contra su
comportamiento como Primer Ministro
ahora dado lo que ocurrió cree que esta
fue una manera de amenazarlo y que esto
significa que puede haber otros ataques
contra su vida
bueno en primer lugar la conferencia de
prensa hecha por el jefe de los
servicios de inteligencia no fue
recomendable digo un jefe de los
servicios de inteligencia Debería ser
una conferencia de prensa si yo contesto
Punto por punto creo que la institución
del ejército saldría perjudicada y no me
gustaría hacer eso porque creo que
necesitamos una fuerza de defensa fuerte
[Música]
pero también creo que la conferencia de
prensa fue una reacción al hecho de que
un muy buen periodista investigador que
estaba presentando mi punto de vista fue
amenazado de muerte se fue del país y
fue asesinado en Kenia hubo un gran
estallido público y las personas
señalaron al establecimiento y me
pareció que la conferencia de prensa fue
más para aplacar la opinión pública
ahora dos semanas después del ataque
imagino que ha reforzado su seguridad
se siente bajo amenaza de asesinato cree
que volverán a intentarlo con el
objetivo de no volver a fallar
fotos
desafortunadamente Márquez sí creo que
podrían volver a intentarlo porque La
amenaza se mantiene la razón por la que
esas personas me querían eliminar es
porque mi partido es de lejos del
partido más popular de Pakistán
elections ganamos el 75% de las
elecciones parciales a pesar del partido
de gobierno del partido en el poder de
la suma de todos los partidos apoyados
por el establecimiento a pesar de todo
eso barrimos las elecciones parciales y
la popularidad ha aumentado básicamente
porque las personas no quieren que esos
criminales sigan gobernando Pakistán 61%
del gabinete tiene cargos de corrupción
Por eso tengo un apoyo público masivo y
creo que para ellos la única manera de
sacarme del camino es eliminarme
Entonces pienso que todavía hay una
amenaza
Steel Walt Disney
cuando usted llamó a su simpatizantes
para que retomaran la marcha hacia la
capital islamabad y dijo que
participaría si su salud se lo permite
la pregunta es está realmente preparado
para hacerlo dado el peligro que acaba
de describir Steven
lo que pasa Marc Es que creo de manera
absoluta en mi fe que dice que la muerte
está en las manos del todopoderoso
tomaré precauciones tomaré más
precauciones que antes pero eso no me
detendrá el miedo en la muerte no me
impedirá luchar por lo que creo que es
una misión luchar por el estado de
derecho en este país Ese es nuestro gran
problema
tenemos instituciones que están por
encima de la ley tenemos mafias
políticas que están por encima de la ley
y por eso el país no puede prosperar
hace 26 años empecé mi movimiento por la
justicia y el estado de derecho y la
amenaza de ser asesinado no me impedirá
retomar esa lucha
resumen
usted quiere elecciones inmediatas el
gobierno dice que no los comicios están
previstos para octubre de 2023 al
pedirle a su simpatizantes que salgan a
las calles no está quizás preparando el
terreno para la violencia algunos
incluso hablan de una posible guerra
civil en Pakistán
Marc he estado en política durante 26
años Siempre me he mantenido dentro de
la Constitución la Constitución me da
derecho a protestar pacíficamente
nuestras protestas Siempre han sido
pacíficas esta marcha será lo que
nuestra Constitución permite protestar
pacíficamente contra lo que está
ocurriendo en Pakistán en este momento
donde un grupo de bandidos se ha
apoderado del país repito
61% están en Libertad bajo fianza por
cargos de corrupción y lo peor es que
nuestra economía se ha hundido
cuando yo me fui el riesgo de impago de
Pakistán era del 5%, hoy es del 75%. el
país se enfrenta una crisis económica
inminente lo que queremos es salir de
esta crisis con unas elecciones libres y
justas
bar personalmente a nosotros no nos
importa si las elecciones son ahora o
dentro de un año vamos a esperar de
todas maneras porque ningún partido ha
tenido el apoyo tan masivo que tenemos
ahora pero el punto es que el país no se
puede permitir seguir tal y como están
esa es la razón de la protesta pacífica
por unas elecciones libres y justas
última pregunta señor después de su
destitución como Primer Ministro a
través de una moción de censura en abril
de 2022 usted acusó a Estados Unidos de
conspirar con las élites pakistaníes
para derrocarlo pero recientemente dijo
no no lo decía en serio Eso quedó atrás
Eso es porque no tiene pruebas para
demostrar lo que dijo algunos de sus
detractores incluso dicen que se inventó
lo que ellos describen como una teoría
de Conspiración
primero primero hubo un documento
cifrado una conversación cifrada secreta
entre nuestro embajador en Washington y
el subsecretario de estado de Estados
Unidos tonalú según este documento
cifrado Donald Luh le dijo a nuestro
embajador sino destituyen a infrancan
como Primer Ministro habrá consecuencias
para Pakistán y deben destituirlo por
moción de censura al día siguiente se
presentó la moción de censura y de
repente el gobierno que estaba teniendo
la mejor ejecución de económica en 17
años tuvimos un índice de crecimiento
económico del 6%. fue destituido ahora
lo que realmente dije es que eso quedó
atrás para mí
solo porque mi gobierno fue derrocado
por Estados Unidos no debía haber dejado
que eso interfiriera con los intereses
del pueblo de Pakistán entre los
intereses del pueblo están tener buenas
relaciones con todos los países en
particular con Estados Unidos que es una
superpotencia eso fue lo que dije nunca
me retracte Al respecto porque el
documento cifrado existe fue presentado
ante el gabinete ante el Consejo de
Seguridad nacional y ahora se le
presentó el presidente del tribunal
supremo y queremos que lleva a cabo una
investigación independiente está fuera
de discusión retractarse al respecto es
cuestión de seguir adelante
Muchas gracias por estar con nosotros en
la entrevista de France 24 desde la Ford
en Pakistán
Gracias a ustedes por verla